these hazy outlines on the horizon are
believed to be a flotilla of russian
navy battleships and they're stalking
the coast of ukraine
imagine one of the world's largest
navies on a war footing staring back at
you
if vladimir putin's opening gambit is to
take the capital keefe then his end game
is to cut off the south of the country
and cities like odessa are strategically
key to that
caught in the middle are innocent people
getting on with their lives in the
sunshine today
until the air raid siren sounds
[Applause]
so from one minute it can look perfectly
normal kids playing on the square and
then the airaid sirens will often the
best thing the only thing a lot of
people can do is just come underground
to get whatever shelter they can
most people we saw seem to ignore it but
valerian and his wife valeria and their
two children
know better than to ignore this siren
they fled nearby nikolai off three days
ago when their street was bombed killing
nine
and furnished it but when the windows
shattered you think the most precious
thing is life
half an hour later they all clear and
cautiously they head back up to the
street this is just one family trying to
keep each other safe
unicef say that millions of children
will be caught up in this war all right
nice to meet you do you want to show me
but for some families this isn't their
first experience of conflict
hannah
she now lives in this derelict building
with her husband and two children
we covered the windows to protect us
from the glass
it's basic but it's home
and there are moments here when things
almost feel normal even in these
desperate times
hannah shows me where they all sleep now
a small square cupboard built from brick
if the shelling is very heavy we have a
basement we will go there quickly
i ask why she doesn't leave
she tells me she's tired of running from
war
this is my hope
the reality though is that children like
daria and angelina are living in very
dangerous times
and the world is praying that they'll
come through it nick martin sky news
odessa